par exemple il y a plus d'hommes et ben
on fera beaucoup plus de guerre parce
que c'est un peu les hommes qui
commandent tout
sur la terre est-ce qu'il y a plus
d'hommes ou plus de femmes je crois plus
d'hommes on les a compté
préfère les hommes aux femmes
tu es déjà remarqué ça
et à quoi est-ce qu'on le remarque
quoi moi je pense plutôt qu'il y a plus
de femmes dans le monde parce que déjà
les classes il y a déjà il y a pas
beaucoup d'hommes et puis des fois dans
les conférences dans les conférences
donc bien sûr il y a des hommes mesdames
conférences de tout il y a plutôt plus
de femmes les muscles ben ils
travaillent alors on les voit pas oh il
y a plus de femmes en tout cas puisque
elles vont toujours en commission
moi pour moi ce que j'aimerais c'est
qu'il y a le même nom d'hommes lui-même
nombre de femmes
ah comme ça il y en aurait chacun qui en
aurait
moi je pense qu'il y a plus de femmes
parce qu'il y a beaucoup d'enfants ici
il y a une seule femme pour faire un
enfant ça se peut pas il faut avoir un
an pour faire un enfant
pour faire un enfant
ça veut pas dire qu'il y a plus de
femmes par exemple il y a plus d'hommes
on fera beaucoup plus de guerre parce
que c'est un peu les hommes qui commande
s'il n'y avait que des femmes sur la
terre il n'y aurait pas de guerre
avec des femmes elles se distribuent
disputent et quand même entre elles il y
aurait beaucoup de casquettes
black sa blague que ça finira jamais
quand il y a des femmes qui téléphone
elle téléphone avec une voix comme ça
et puis elle se prend le plus belle
possible t'es dit que les hommes ils
sont normaux qui sont pas trop ils sont
pas trop comme les femmes
partout
[Musique]
des fois
naturel quand on met du rouge à lèvres
c'est pas bien
je trouve que les femmes se maquille pas
pour seulement pour plaire aux hommes
mais c'est aussi parce qu'elles sont
coquettes
ma maman elle met beaucoup de bleu
j'aime pas et non mais partout
parce que ça fait ça fait plus féminin
sans rouge à lèvres tout ça est-ce que
les femmes peuvent faire tout ce que les
hommes font
quels sont les métiers que ne peuvent
pas pratiquer
déjà le tracteur moi je sais qu'on tire
le tracteur elles sont un petit peu
moins habiles pour conduire des des
avions pour faire via peur je me demande
pourquoi les hommes se croient super
héros femme est-ce que les femmes sont
plus intelligentes que les hommes ou
est-ce que le contraire
la même intelligence seulement les
hommes en plus de chance parce qu'ils
ont beaucoup plus de droits que les
femmes c'est vrai dans quel domaine par
exemple je sais pas il y a 20 ans en
arrière les femmes n'avaient presque pas
le droit de skier c'est plutôt réservé
pour les hommes quoi puis il y avait
aussi presque pas le droit de voter mais
ça a changé heureusement est-ce qu'il
reste des choses que les femmes ne
peuvent pas faire et que les hommes
peuvent
je crois plus elles peuvent pas faire
curé les
[Musique]